- À quelques jours de Noël,
plusieurs Québécois se d'annuler
les rassemblements de famille.
- On gère au jour le jour, à
l'heure. On se texte : On va-tu
chez vous? On y
- Les nt nombreux.
Les optimistes sont plus rares.r
de problème. Ils sont tous
vaccinés. On va être 10-12
avec les cinq petits-enfants.
ici, au Marché de Noël
allemand, la majorité
des citoyens rencontrés sontjà
annulé leurs partys, sans
attendre l'annonce de nouvelles
par le premier ministre,
is Legault, mercredi.
- Ça va être tranquille
chez moi avec ma maman,ut.
- Làvraiment...
Tous les plans sont chamboulés.
Pas le choix de s'adapter.
tu sais, on ne sait pas quand
va revoir nos proches.
Ça fait que c'est décevant.
- Que l'on vive dans le déni,
la trila résignation,
le psychologue Marc André Dufour
rappelle qu'il flieu
de les refouler.
MARC ANDRÉ DUFOUR,
psychologue clinicien
- Il y a de lafrustration. Et me
si on comprend rationnellement,
même si on sait que c'est la
chose à faire, que les services
de san- Il explique que plusieus
Québécois risquent d'éprouver
le phénomène de l'impuissance
apprise, un concept bien connu
Malgré les règles sanitaires,
malgré la vaccination et
les nombreux eff tout de même
en force.
- On perd notre motivation,
on devient frustré parce
qu'on
porte qu'est-ce qu'on
fait, peu importe nos efforts,
les résultats sont pas làe sortr
de cette impuissance-là
en se
la mareuvre qu'oeuvre qu'oeuvrea
encore dans notre existence
pour avoir un Noël qui va
quand voir àvoir àvoir àvoir àvt
du bon sens, même si ce n'est
- Car jusqu'à nouvel ordre,il es
de se voir en plein air...
et de rigoler un peu
avec les lutins du père Noël.
Ici Pascal Poinlane,